>> Laura: TODAY'S UPSET
ELECTION IN ALABAMA,
TUESDAY'S UPSET ELECTION IN
ALABAMA HAS GIVEN DEMOCRATS
A ROSY VISION OF A RETURN TO
GLORY AND I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THAT'S LED A LET THAT
THAT'S LED A PET THAT
THAT'S LED A PLE THAT
PUNDITS PREDICTING UTTER
DOOM FOR 2018.
>> YOU ARE WATCHING THIS
170-YEAR-OLD INSTITUTION
SWIFTLY MARCHING ITSELF
TOWARD DESTRUCTION.
>> CAN A DIVIDED REALLY MORE
THAN DIVIDED INTERNALLY
COMPETITIVE AND INTERNALLY
ANGRY COMBATIVE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, CAN IT WIN IN 2018
AND 2020?
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO
RECRUIT SIMILAR TYPES OF
CANDIDATES IN SENATE RACES
ISSUE FOR THE G.O.P.
AND LET'S THINK ABOUT THIS
REALLY CAREFULLY.
MITCH MCCONNELL IS REALLY
SMART AND WILEY IN SO MANY
EXPERIENCE.
IS HE LOOKING TO KIND OF IN
SOME WAYS EXPLOIT THE
EMBARRASSMENT IN ALABAMA TO
MAYBE KNOCK OUT VIABLE
POPULIST CANDIDATES
ELSEWHERE?
THERE ARE NO ROY MOORES BUT
THEY ARE POPULIST SO THEY
CONFLATE THE TWO?
I'M THINKING OF PEOPLE LIKE
NEVADA.
WE HAVE GOT TO THINK ABOUT
THIS.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
HAVE JUST A FEW NATIONAL
FIGURES TO SUPPORT YOU.
NO, NO.
G.O.P. TO SURVIVE JUST LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID.
KELLI WARD, REMEMBER, TRIED
AND FAILED TO BEAT MCCAIN
BUT, I'M TELLING YOU, SHE IS
SO TRYING TO TAG HER AS FAR
RIGHT AS THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" ATTEMPTED TO DO TODAY
IS ABSURD.
SHE WOULD BE A FINE GENERAL
ELECTION CANDIDATE.
AND THE PARTY NEEDS MORE
STRONG, SMART WOMEN.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS
THIS, EXCLUSIVELY IS RNC
CHAIR WOMAN RONNA
MCDANIEL.
SHE HUDDLE YOU HAD UP WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY AND
THIS IS HER FIRST INTERVIEW
SINCE THE ELECTION IN
ALABAMA.
RONNA, HOW ARE YOU.
>> GREAT TO BE HERE.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Laura: MERRY CHRISTMAS.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
THE ALABAMA RACE WAS A REAL
BODY BLOW FOR THE
REPUBLICANS.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT BUT FOR
THE REPUBLICANS TO ELKS TRAP
PLACE LIKE LEARS ARIZONA,
PARTICULARLY KELLI WARD FOR
JEFF FLAKE'S SEAT VOTE NO.
CAN'T DO THAT BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO BE ANOTHER ROY
MOORE IS THAT FAIR?
>> THAT'S NOT FAIR.
ALABAMA IS UNIQUE, SPECIAL
GOING TO BE A BELLWETHER IN
BALLOT.
SO MANY CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
GO INTO EACH SPECIAL
ELECTIONS.
CANDIDATES DO MATTER.
DO YOU NEED GOOD CANDIDATES.
WE NEED TO LET THE VOTERS
MAKE THAT DECISION.
THE VOTERS DON'T LOVE
WASHINGTON COMING IN.
>> Laura: MCCONNELL.
>> WE LEARNED THAT WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP VOTERS
WANTED TO DECIDE THEIR OWN
FATE AND WHO THEIR NOMINEE
IS GOING TO BE.
WE NEED TO BE SWIMMING IN
THE SAME DIRECTION IF WE'RE
GOING TO WIN ELECTIONS.
>> Laura: WROTE A PIECE IN
REPUBLICANS.
HE SAID REPUBLICANS MUST
PASS TAX CUTS THIS YEAR.
CONTINUE THE ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
AND THEY NEED TO SPEND
CHANGING CURRENT PATTERNS
AND MAXIMIZING THEIR CHANCES
TO KEEP THE HOUSE.
THEY HAVE CONTINUE TO CREASE
THEIR SENATE MAJORITY BY
FIVE OR SIX, HE SAYS, AND SO
THEY WILL BE STRONG ENOUGH
TO REALLY HOLD THAT MAJORITY
DIFFICULT.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT
ANALYSIS.
>> I THINK NEWT IS RIGHT ON
AND THE RNC IS RIGHT ON
TRACK TO DO THOSE THINGS.
WE RAISED RECORD MONEY.
JUST ANNOUNCED A NEW RECORD
IN NOVEMBER.
ALREADY IN 18 STATES.
GROUND THAN EVER BEFORE.
WE ARE ALSO DOING OUTREACH
TO COMMUNITIES THAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN IN BEFORE.
WE HAVE TO START SHOWING UP
AND HAVING A CONVERSATION
AND TALK ABOUT THE THINGS WE
HAVE IN COMMON.
I THINK NEWT IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
WE ARE GOING TO COMPETE FOR
AT LOVE SENATE SEATS.
THE MAP LOOKS GOOD FOR US.
>> Laura: WHAT DID THE
THAT WERE NOT PRIVATE.
WHAT WAS HIS MOOD LIKE.
>> IT WAS GREAT.
AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE HAD A LOT OF RNC MEMBERS
IS HE ALWAYS LOOKING TO HELP
PEOPLE'S LIVES BE BETTER.
AND IS HE FOCUSED ON TAX
CUTS.
WE NEED TO PASS TAX CUTS.
WE JUST PUT UP A WEBSITE
GETTING MORE JOBS AND
SENDING MORE MONEY HOME IN
PEOPLE'S PAYCHECKS.
>> Laura: THE RNC OFFICIAL
THAT QUIT FOR ROY MOORE.
YOU GUYS SHOULD HAVE
SUPPORTED ROY MOORE IN THE
END.
>> WE HAD 1 OUT OF 168.
OVERWHELMINGLY THE RNC
MEMBERS UNDERSTAND OUR ROLE
AT THE RNC ISING
POLITICAL ARM AT THE OF THE
KEEP THAT SEAT.
WE ALWAYS SAID LET ALABAMA
DECIDE.
WE KNEW THESE ALLEGATIONS
WERE DEEPLY CONCERNING.
THEY WERE INCREDIBLY
TROUBLING, AT THE END OF THE
DAY, ALABAMAIANS MADE THEIR
SAID, I KNOW A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS ARE GLAD HE IS
NOT HERE, BUT JUST FOR MY
AGENDA, I WISH WE HAD THAT
SEAT.
THAT'S A PRAGMATIC WAY OF
LOOKING AT IT I KNOW IT
HORRIFIES A LOT OF
LOSING THAT SEAT IS A BLOW
TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> YEAH.
TROUBLING AND CONCERNING.
AND DISQUALIFYING IF THEY'RE
PROVEN TRUE.
>> Laura: HE HAS EVEN
CONCEDED THE ELECTION YET
ROY MOORE.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> Laura: RIDING HIS HORSE
TO THE NEXT SEAT?
>> Laura: I ASK ON MY RADIO
YES I WILL WRITE 10 BUCKS OR
50 BUCKS, THEY WRITE A NOTE.
WHAT'S THE NUMBER ONE THING
PEOPLE.
>> RIGHT NOW I'M GETTING A
LOT OF MERRY CHRISTMAS CARDS
WHICH IS GREAT.
I ALWAYS LOOK AT THEM FOR
YOU, IT IS TAX CUTS.
WE HAVE TO SHOW THAT WE CAN
PASS A BIG AGENDA ITEM AND
GOVERN WITH THE MAJORITY.
THEY WANT TO SEE PEOPLE --
THEY WANT THE CONGRESS TO
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: ISN'T THE LATTER
>> SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT'S
THE RNC.
RAISING.
>> Laura: HOW DO WE BECOME
THE.
>> IF EVERY ELECTION WE
WRITE OFF CALIFORNIA AND NEW
DYNAMIC?
>> WE WILL BE IN CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSIONAL IN PLACE.
WE HAVE TO DO THAT WITH
NEVER SHUT IT DOWN.
WE HAVE TO START SHOWING UP
BLUE STATES.
I WAS A CHAIR OF A STATE
THAT NOBODY THOUGHT
PRESIDENTIALLY.
WE WON IT FOR THE FIRST TIME
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO PUT RESOURCES IN
AND PUT OUR MESSAGE IN AND
SHOW UP AND STAY.
>> Laura: SHOWING UP.
WHEN TRUMP WENT TO DETROIT
THAT BLACK CHURCH.
HE HAS TO DO THAT ONCE EVERY
COUPLE WEEKS.
>> HE WENT TO DETROIT AND
FLINT.
>> Laura: WOULD YOU ADVISE
HIM TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
>> Laura: CONTINUE THAT PUSH
INTO MINORITY AREAS THAT CAN
BE HELPED BY ECONOMIC
REFORM.
>> HE IS TALKING ABOUT
SKILLED TRADES.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT JOBS.
>> WE NEED TO SHOW UP AND
GIVE OUR MESSAGE BECAUSE
>> Laura: IS HE TELLING YOU
TO DROP YOUR MAIDEN NAME.
>> THERE ARE THREE REASONS
WHY I HAVE EMPHASIZED
MCDANIEL MORE.
MY KIDS SEE THEIR MOM A LOT
LESS.
WE HAVE WAY MORE IMPORTANT
THINGS TO TALK ABOUT.
I LIKE BOTH NAMES.
>> I HAVE THEM BOTH.